hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt's endlich mal
wieder eine torte von mir
und zwar habe ich euch ja versprochen
dass ich dieses jahr ein paar
geburtstagstorten mache und da eben alle
ansprechen also anfänger
fortgeschrittene und profis kann ich das
sagen selber kein profi aber auf jeden
fall auf jedem level irgendwie eine
torte für euch gestaltet und viele waren
sehr an auflege trockene interessiert
also an trocken die man eben einfach
fertigstellt und dann so ein motiv
aufleger drauflegt da habe ich mich
jetzt erkundigt und habe jetzt da
verschiedene aufleger für euch und zwar
gibt es da den unterschied dass es
einmal die fladen gibt das war bisher
immer so dass standort und dann gibt's
jetzt auch auflege aus zucker aber
vergleich vielleicht wieso man überhaupt
aufleger nehmen kann oder wer sie nehmen
könnte und zwar wisst ihr ja dass ich
selbst auch berufstätig bin und im
moment sehr viel zu tun habt für mich
kamen so auflege eigentlich nie infrage
weil ich ja erst oder kreative mensch
bin ich mache lieber alles selbst und
gestartete eben dann auch meine motive
selber aber zwischendurch kommt
natürlich auch mal vor dass ich für den
kindergeburtstag zum beispiel torten
machen muss und ich habe eben nur 23
stunden zeit und dann reicht es halt
einfach nicht um die torte selbst zu
backen und dann zu dekorieren
deswegen habe ich jetzt schon mal nicht
so dass sondern aufleger gegriffen grad
die kinder für die macht es keinen
unterschied ob ich das jetzt selbst
macht oder ob ich mir jetzt das einfach
machen aufleger nehme weil er gerade bei
kindern ist es so dass die zum beispiel
diese aufleger gerne mögen weil sie ja
diese motive aus dem fernsehen oder aus
den büchern kennen wenn ich euch jetzt
hier zb dieses hier zeige cars kennt
wahrscheinlich jeder junge
wahrscheinlich auch ein paar mädchen die
lieben diese cars die erkennen dass
sogar an diesen zeichen und für die
kinder macht es wirklich keinen
unterschied ob ich auflege nehmen oder
ob ich kompliziert und aufwendig das
auto eben selbst gestalten oder gerade
auch für kleine kinder hier diese
philipp werde
also da stehen dies haben ihre auch
schon drauf und da macht man denen
wirklich eine freude damit unser sport
inside
ich habe jetzt keine opladen mit motiv
hier weil ich die einfach nicht gekauft
habt weil ich sehr nicht verwenden würde
ich hatte einen auflieger mit einer
platte das zeige ich euch später im
video und zwar war es so ein fußballfeld
das wollte ich einfach mal ausprobieren
aber da zeige ich euch dann auch was wir
schwierigkeiten ich dabei hatte eine
oblate kennt ihr gibt es zum backen zum
beispiel für lebkuchen oder makronen ihr
wisst es wird aus stärke hergestellt
erbrechtlich und auf diesen auflagen
waren eben bisher immer diese ganzen
aufleger und ich habe jetzt aber dazu
entschieden diese aufreger aus zucker zu
nehmen weil sie flexibel sind kann die
knicken und machen wenig möchte mit dem
nicht kaputt zerbrechen nicht
man kann nicht machen tolle schau nicht
so als ob man vielleicht nicht drücken
diese aufleger gibt es mit verschiedenen
motiven und ich habe mich jetzt heute zu
entschlossen eine mit dem kv aufleger zu
machen und den aufleger haben einen
durchmesser von 16 cm
deswegen werde ich meinen kuchen da eben
die basis sein soll
in einer 20 zentimeter springform button
als basis für jeden kuchen nehme den ihr
möchtet ihr könnt die aufleger nicht nur
auf und orten legen sondern auch auf
sahnetorten auftreten bei sahne müsst
ihr nur aufpassen dass sie den aufleger
kurz vor dem servieren drauflegt weil
sich ja dann der zucker durch die sahne
auf löst aber so für eine halbe stunde
kriegsschiff auf buttercreme oder gar
stellt ihr das einfach drauf legen
da passiert nichts weil die creme eben
nicht so viel feuchtigkeit enthält und
wenn ich das ganze auch mal von der
torte macht können das einfach drauf
machen und da passiert gar nichts der
aufleger bleibt schön glatt und zieht
auch keine feuchtigkeit
ich werde euch heute einen job zeigen da
ist richtig schön saftig und schön weiß
ihr könnt da natürlich aber auch einen
anderen tag benutzen
ich werde euch da auch mal meine zitrone
torte wenn
bananen torte verlinkten und auch meine
wickelt heute ihr könnt dann nämlich
auch eine wickelt heute drunter machen
und dieser schokokuchen den ich gleich
machen soll jetzt nur eine idee sein und
steige ich jetzt einmal die zutaten und
zeigt euch wie ich den teig herstellen
für die 20 bzw 22 cm springform braucht
ihr drei eier
die habe ich jetzt schon getrennt in
eigelb und eiweiß eine prise salz 160
gramm zucker 160 gramm butter die ist
schön zimmer räume und richtig weiß ich
habe hier 70 milliliter wasser da könnte
auch milch oder butter milch benutzen
könnte aber auch ganz gut fand abhole
irgendwas benutzen oder den saft hier
habe ich 100 gramm mehl 20 g
speisestärke und 30 von kaka und co
und wenn ihr keinen job machen wollt
benutzte einfach keinen kakaopulver
sondern nimmt einfach noch mal statt 30
kakaopulver 30 gramm stärke oder mail
hier habe ich eine prise natron also so
eine messerspitze und einen halben
teelöffel backpulver meinen backpapier
oder beziehungsweise meine back folie
mit meinem back rahmen habe ich schon
hingerichtet das ist ne 20 cm springform
ihr könnt das ganze aber auch im 22
erwarten
jetzt kam zuerst das eiweiß im
autoschlüssel da kommt die prise salz
mit dazu damit die eiweiß struktur
schnell zerstört wird und es wird jetzt
einmal schöne steif geschlagen
und wenn es noch steif ist gebe ich hier
noch den kristallisation und lass das
noch mal zwei bis drei minuten früher
bis richtig schöne besi wasser
entstanden ist
und das eiweiß ist richtig schön steil
wie man sieht und das fühle ich jetzt
einmal um
da möchte ich dann nämlich gleich in der
gleichen schlüssel die restlichen
zutaten verrühren und das kann ich kurz
zur seite stellen
hier gebe ich jetzt die butter rein und
auch die eigene und das lasse ich jetzt
noch mal schön cremig rühren
und jetzt muss er den hörer austauschen
mit dem schneebesen darf man nämlich
eigentlich nur eiweiß und sahne und so
weiter schlagen für die mutter habe ich
jetzt noch genommen und gebt da jetzt
die hälfte von meinen trockenen zutaten
mit dazu macht es nämlich auf zwei mal
noch die hälfte des mülls backpulver
monat rum gebe ich gleich mit dazu und
sperrte es jetzt verriet und
währenddessen das wasser mit einrühren
lassen und dann kommt während dem rühren
eben auch noch die zweite ladung mit
rein so dass eben ein schöner glatter
teig entsteht
den habe ich jetzt ganz kurz auf
höchster stufe verrührt das dürfte dann
auch mal ganz kurz machen
unternehmt ihr euch euren eischnee und
hebt es in zwei portionen unter
den teig gebt ihr dann in eure form wie
gesagt bei mir hier dieser backend und
wenn ihr denn da auch ein bisschen an
den rand streicht dann geht beim backen
etwas gleichmäßiger auf und stark kuchen
wird jetzt bei 160 grad ober und
unterhitze gebacken und zwar für etwa 30
bis 40 minuten natürlich kommt die
backzeit darauf an je nachdem was für
eine backform ihr benutzt ihr macht
einfach die stäbchen holt es zeige ich
euch gleich im anschluss so sieht mein
tag jetzt aus und stäbchen probe heißt
ich stecke den holzstab hinein und
ziehen wieder raus und wenn nichts mehr
dran hängen bleibt dann ist der teig
richtig gut
so lasse ich das jetzt abkühlen und
macht dann weiter und meint abkühlt
welche zurzeit die garage stellen und
zwar nämlich jetzt einfach mal ganz
normale fan peter schokolade und sahne
und werdet daraus die creme herstellen
aber wie gesagt könnt ihr auch ganz
normale saale benutzen oder irgend eine
creme die euch gefällt ich zeige euch
einmal die zutaten hierfür und zeigt
euch dann wie es weitergeht dafür
braucht ihr zwei zutaten und zwar einmal
schlagsahne und einmal schokolade
ich stehe jetzt sagt bitter schokolade
und deswegen nehme ich jetzt schokolade
und sahne im gleichen verhältnis also
jeweils 200 gramm sahne und 200 gramm
schokolade wenn ihr vollmilch schokolade
oder weiße schokolade nehmt verändert
sich das verhältnis aber dann schaut
doch wie gesagt mal auf meinem blog
vorbei die schokolade habe ich jetzt
klein gehackt das war nämlich kuvertüre
aber ihr könnt auch ganz normale blog
schokolade nehmen oder ganz normale
zartbitterschokolade und einfach die
feinen rippchen brechen und dann müsste
die eben nicht klein hacken die sahne
mit diesem topf erhitzt können aber zum
beispiel auch in der mikrowelle machen
und ich werde jetzt einmal aufkochen
lassen dann vom herd nehmen und dann
kommt die schokolade mit dazu
die sahne kocht jetzt nehme ich sie vom
herd runter und da gebe ich jetzt die
schokolade mit rein und schaut dass die
schokolade schön bedeckt ist und so las
ich das ganze jetzt einfach stehen so
etwa zwei bis drei minuten und western
verrühren
nach ein paar minuten können wir das
ganze mal umrühren
dann hat sich nämlich die schokolade
drin
höchst und dann wird das ganze einfach
mit einem mixstab fein püriertem zu
feiern und homogen gemacht
und so wie das ganze jetzt abgedeckt und
angeblich das in den kühlschrank und ist
richtig schön kalt ist wenn es mal ganz
schnell gehen muss kann man das aber
auch ganz gut ins gefrierfach stellen
da ist es wirklich innerhalb von einer
halben stunde abgekühlt während die
garage auch abkühlt werde ich einmal
zeigen wie ich das nicht immer eckigen
und haute gemacht habt und zwar habe ich
am anfang schon erwähnt dass ich eine
plattenaufleger hatte und zwar was ein
fußballfeld und dafür habe ich all
diesen gleichen tag in der eckigen
backform gebacken und habe dann den
kuchen mit ghanas bestrichen und mit
grünem fonda und überzogen
da habe ich dann das fußballfeld eben
drauf geklebt und habe dann festgestellt
dass sich ebendiese oblate leicht auf
höchst wenn man da eben etwas klemmt
klebert unter gibt steht auch auf der
packung drauf motto plattenaufleger nur
auf trockene flächen geben das heißt ich
jetzt trocken auf dem von und legen
können
ich hätte eventuell etwas schokolade an
die ecken geben können um das eben
anzukleben weil ansonsten ja die oblate
ständig runterfällt wollen wir auch
nicht
und da gab es eben im paket mit dabei
noch so ein paar spielfiguren und zwei
fußballtore und das hat dem kleinen
fehlers natürlich ganz gut gefallen weil
sind großer fußballfan ist dieses
fußballfest gibt es eben supermarkt zu
kaufen
das habe ich bei globus gekauftes mist
aber auch sonst überall geben denke ich
das wollte ich einfach mal kurz und
nebenbei zeigen und meine garage und
mein kuchen sind jetzt abgekühlt ich
werde euch zeigen wie ich den kuchen mit
der garage einstreiche und wie ich ihnen
dann bleibt streiche das ist nämlich
besonders wichtig und da zeige ich euch
jetzt einfach mal wie ich das mache
wie gesagt dass der kuchen jetzt richtig
schön kalt und ihr könnt jetzt hier
sehen dass da oben etwas eingeschränkt
ist also dass er hier wie man hier sehen
kann
unten etwas breiter ist und ich möchte
es jetzt noch schön zurecht schneiden
und jetzt habe ich ihn einfach mit so
einer palette an der schön kalt deswegen
ist auch richtig fest und drehen einmal
um damit ich die glatte oberfläche oben
habe und setzte ihn auf eine kuchen
platte und auch der kuchen platte habe
ich denn jetzt positioniert und möchte
das jetzt daran schön sauber bleibt
deswegen gehe ich da was papierstreifen
pumpen
hier habe ich jetzt meine gage die war
ganz kurz im gefrierfach zum abkühlen
aber sie hat jetzt wieder
zimmertemperatur
und so soll sie auch sein damit man so
schön verstreichen kann die darf nämlich
nicht zu kalt sein
und das ist eben das was ich immer sagt
der kuchen soll kalt sein
die ghanaische zimmer war und dann kann
man das auch richtig schön verstreichen
die erste schicht trage ich einfach mit
so einer palette auf und zwar braucht
ihr die erste schicht damit die krümel
gebunden werden wir eben eine ebene
fläche gefolgt
dann streicht das hier noch mal schön
glatt mit der palette und ihr merkt dann
auch dass die kanal richtig schön fest
wird auf der oberfläche der kuchen
überhaupt ist die erste schicht muss
auch gar nicht so perfekt zeigen ich
gebe dir jetzt mal für in den
kühlschrank für etwa 15 minuten damit
sie fest wird und dann mache ich gleich
weiter jetzt muss die torte noch richtig
glatt gestrichen werden und dafür gebe
ich da jetzt noch mal etwas ganz oben
drauf
und auch der rand welt noch mal sauber
ab gestrichen
doch die oberfläche
und wenn ihr dann zufrieden zeit könnte
das papier wegnehmen
und da wo ihr nicht drankommt könnte
einfach eine palette oder messer nehmen
ein geschirrtuch oder so seeber
außensichel und könnte es dann hier
schön sauber machen
wie gesagt könnt ihr euren torten auf
lege ich auch direkt auf die ghana
stehen wenn er das so haben möchtet
könnt noch ein paar sandhausen rum geben
und dann habt ihr schon die fertige
torte oder ihr macht eben weiter so wie
jetzt bei mir ich werde jetzt etwas
roten wand nehmen und den damit eben
einleiten wenn ihr einsteiger zeit würde
ich empfehlen den von dann erstmal zu
kaufen damit ihr überhaupt wisst wie der
in der konsistenz ist und wenn ihr dann
etwas geübt sein könnte den vonlanthen
natürlich auch selbst machen dazu habe
ich ein rezept werde ich aber auch bald
mal ein marshmallow von dann prozent
geben und ich mach das mittlerweile so
dass ich meine freunde und lieber kaufe
einfach aus zeitgründen ich habe einfach
nicht mehr die zeit dazu dass alles
selbst zu machen und jetzt zeige ich
euch einfach mal wie ich den kuchen
dekorieren und was ihr dazu eben noch an
werkzeug benötigt zuerst einmal schaue
ich mir natürlich an wie viel fand ich
brauch' ich habe c die torte die hat
jetzt nach dem backen etwa dann
durchmesser von 19 zentimetern und ist
auch nicht sehr hoch so etwa 3 cm hoch
das heißt mir dürfte eigentlich eine 250
gramm packungen von den reichen
wie gesagt nämlich den roten und ich
habe mich dazu entschieden eben diesen
fertigen zu nehmen
der muss jetzt schön verknetet werden
damit er richtig schön weich wird dazu
nehme ich mir einfach etwas paris oft
und werde damit meine hände einfetten
und den einmal weich kneten
diesen von dann muss ich jetzt ausrollen
und zwar habe ich ja wie gesagt den
kuchen von etwa 19 zentimeter und durch
mainz haben und sagen wir mal 4 cm höhe
das heißt ich muss zu den 19 cm noch
einmal die 14
dafür den rand zu rechnen das sind dann
etwa 23 24 cm und damit es schön reicht
werde ich das mindestens jetzt 30 cm
groß ausrollen
dann reicht es nämlich auf jeden fall
zum ausrollen benutze ich bäcker stärke
früher habe ich puderzucker benutzt habe
mich dann aber immer darüber geärgert
dass dann davon dann zu klebrig wurde
und nicht mehr von der arbeitsfläche weg
wollte dann habe ich mit speisestärke
probiert da war dann das problem dass er
mir zu stellen zu abgerissen ist weil
daneben trocken wird und diese becken
stärke ist praktisch so eine kombination
aus stärke und zucker mit der klambt es
wirklich suchen
um zu gucken ob es passt halte ich das
einmal drüber und ihr seht es passt
wunderbar also ich habe hier an den
seiten immer noch sehr viel platz
dann wird s angehoben ihr könnt es so
auf der hand machen
oder er nimmt den ausrollt starb dazu
und schlagt es einmal drüber dann kommt
die tomate und dann wird es hier seine
trümmer gelegt einmal glatt streichen
und hier müsst ihr aufpassen wenn es
eben auch einer hohen tortenplatte liegt
dass es hier daran nicht so arg
unterzieht sonst bekommt ihr hier ist er
ein dass es am besten ist es wenn es
natürlich flach liegt aber wie geht es
jetzt so wie bei mir direkt auf seiner
platte macht müsste da wirklich
aufpassen und am besten schneidet ihr
das gleich weg
dann die seiten runter
da unsere schönen antreten
und dann kann es schön glatt gestrichen
werden
findet euch den aufleger nehmen und
ihnen auf der folie herauslösen und
jetzt habt ihr hier noch mal so eine
trägerfolie darunter die muss natürlich
auch weg und ich habe jetzt gerade nicht
aufgepasst und habt es hier
weggeschnitten in egal macht nix und
diesen aufleger könnt ihr dann mit etwas
zucker kleber ankleben das rezept dazu
habe ich in meinem pinguin video gegeben
dass verlinkt ich euch in der infobox
ihr könnt aber auch einfach mit etwas
wasser anbringen so würde dann die torte
aussehen ihr könnt ihr jetzt auch so
lassen oder wie gesagt auch weiter
gestalten
ich zeige euch jetzt einfach noch wie
ich hier den rand noch etwas verschönern
würde
mit so einem kleinen muster aber die
torte sieht auch so schon richtig
komplett und fertig aus wenn ihr das
natürlich zu einem geburtstag macht
würde ich da jetzt vielleicht noch eine
kerze reinstecken als ziffer und
eventuell auch etwas von land und leuten
passte den namen darunter schreiben oder
auch mit zucker schrift das geht ja auch
aber wie ihr gesehen habt im
handumdrehen habe ich diese torte hier
gestaltet für den rand nämlich etwas
weißem fordernd und roll den dünn aus
unternehme ich mir meinen lineal und
schneit es einmal zurecht und das
schneide ich jetzt 1,5 cm breiten umfang
meiner tochter habe ich mit so einem
maßband ausgemessen und es sind knapp 60
cm genau zu sein 59 und werde deswegen
dass sie in zwei teile teilen
ich schneide jetzt hier großzügig weg
und macht 30
jetzt kommt dann auch etwas schwarz mit
dazu ich möchte das ganze so ein
bisschen wie bei der formel 1 mit dieser
fahne eben dekorieren und möchte da
jetzt eben schwarze und weiße quadrate
drauf
wenn ihr dieses band jetzt an der torte
befestigen wollt nehmt ihr euch etwas
zucker kleber oder wasser ich will
lieber streicht es schön mit einem
pinsel drauf und dann wird es hier darum
herum gelegt
so können zum beispiel auch mal unschöne
enden und abschlüsse kaschieren so wie
bei mir hier ich habe hier ausgesehen
zuviel weggeschnitten
und jetzt könnt ihr damit beginnen diese
kleinen quadrate daran zu befestigen
und natürlich macht man das hier über
diese stelle über die ihr geklebt hat
die fertige text sieht jetzt so aus ihr
könnt ihr natürlich ausgestaltung wie
ihr das möchte und ich habe jetzt
insgesamt sagen wir mal mit dem backen
und abkühlen und mit der ganzen bauzeit
zusammen vielleicht zu zwei stunden
gebraucht also das ist wirklich sehr
schnell gemacht und natürlich werde ich
jetzt auch in den weiteren videos auch
andere taten machen die linke für die
aufleger setze ich euch in die info box
und auf diese weise könnt ihr natürlich
auch foto trocken herstellen ich habe
das auch schon öfter gemacht dass ich
fotos ebenso als druck habe ausdrucken
lassen und habe damit daneben eine torte
dekoriert dass ich das gleiche prinzip
ihrem rad die torte vor
und dann kommt eben dieser foto aufleger
drauf das hat sich auch einen link in
der infobox und wie gesagt werde ich
dann jetzt bald noch so zweidimensionale
und auch dreidimensionale torten machen
falls ihr die ideen habt oder falls ihr
gewisse vorstellungen und wünsche habt
könnt ihr die mir gerne mitteilen
ich bin da nämlich gerade noch etwas auf
das suche was für ein motiv ich wählen
soll
was euch jetzt eben am besten gefällt
ich bin so ein angry birds torte ganz
lustig aber vielleicht habt ihr da ja
auch andere ideen oder andere wünsche
und das projekt wird den kuchen gibt's
natürlich auf meinem blog auf www
boys-day ist orten welt.de
ich wünsche euch noch einen ganz schönen
tag lasst mir auf jeden fall einen
kommentar mit einem hund steuer oder mit
einer idee oder sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal wieder bis falsch ist